Nunca mejor dicho, Los Países Bajos son el
tercer país más bajo del mundo.
Y creedme que de verdad son bajos.
Su elevación media es de tan solo 30 metros
y alrededor de una cuarta parte de su territorio
está por debajo del nivel del mar.
Todo esto es algo que hace que los
Países Bajos sean también uno de los países
más amenazados por la subida del nivel del
mar que potencialmente
puede provocar el calentamiento  global.
[Un momento, ¿que cuál es el primero?
Seguro que muchos lo sabéis, las Maldivas
cuya altitud media es de apenas 2 metros.
Lo cual resulta increíble, sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta que a pesar de ser una isla
plana en mitad del océano, su capital, Malé,
es una de las ciudades más densamente pobladas
de todo el planeta]
Dicho lo cual, eso lo dejaremos para otra
ocasión porque en este vídeo vamos a centrarnos
en los Países Bajos y en algunos de los pronósticos
más terribles que los acechan.
Es posible que en alguna que otra ocasión
todos hayáis visto imágenes como esta que
veis ahora pantalla.
Imágenes, recreaciones y mapas en los que
se muestra como la mayor parte del territorio
de los Países Bajos - incluida la loca capital
de Amsterdam - desaparecerá bajo el mar como
consecuencia del derretimiento de los polos.
Algo que tarde o tempra obligaría lógicamente
a los neerlandeses a emigrar en masa a países
como Alemania.
Y es que, veréis, según las estimaciones
científicas el nivel del mar podría crecer
entre 30 o 77 centímetros para el año 2100.
Los peores escenarios hablan incluso de 200
centímetros, 2 metros.
Y, amigos, aunque eso pueda no parecernos
mucho lo cierto es que lo es.
No sólo porque esa subida del nivel del mar
lograría inundar muchos terrenos tan bajos
como los que podemos encontrar en los Países
Bajos sino también porque multiplicaría
el daño de las inundaciones, las crecidas
y los desbordamientos de los ríos en caso
de tormentas, por ejemplo.
[Lo que, por supuesto, se traduciría en vidas
humanas, cosechas y ciudades destrozadas,
terrenos anegados, etcétera, etcétera.]
Sin embargo, un momento porque en este vídeo
os vamos a mostrar cómo los los habitantes
de los Países Bajos están trabajando ya
para enfrentarse a este gigantesco reto: lidiar
con el crecimiento del nivel del mar.
Algo para lo que tienen dos opciones.
Ni más, ni menos.
La primera es luchar contra el agua, construyendo
diques más altos, presas más grandes y más
resistentes e infraestructuras de contención
más poderosas.
La segunda opción es asumir al nuevo
vecino, el agua, y tratar de controlarlo y
convivir con él.
(La población de los actuales Países Bajos
lleva siglos, incluso desde antes de la Edad
Media, sufriendo los efectos de enormes inundaciones
que periódicamente terminaban con la vida
de decenas y decenas de miles de personas.
Tan solo la conocida como inundación de Santa
Lucía del año 1287 terminó con la vida
de entre 50.000 y 80.000 personas.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué?
Ya en esa época existían diques de contención,
una obra hidráulica avanzada para la época.
Hablamos de hace más de 700 años.)
Tal y como podéis ver hablamos de un pueblo
muy acostumbrado a convivir y luchar contra
el agua a partes iguales.
Pero, amigos, ahora las grandes preguntas
que nos podemos hacer son…
¿Cómo diantres se están preparando los
neerlandeses para el futuro?
¿Realmente se puede hacer algo?
¿Podrán los Países Bajos sobrevivir al
calentamiento global si finalmente se produce
el derretimiento parcial de los polos y el
consiguiente incremento del nivel del mar?
Atentos.
(¿RIESGO NATURAL O RIESGO HUMANO?)
Vale, no sorprendemos a nadie.
Es evidente que las crecidas son un gran riesgo
para los Países Bajos, así como para buena
parte del mundo.
[Vale, sí, por supuesto si algo caracteriza
al ser humano ha sido precisamente su capacidad
de adaptarse, enfrentarse a las adversidades
y superar prácticamente cualquier riesgo
que la naturaleza nos ha planteado.
Pero, amigos. de momento esta amenaza está
sobre la mesa.]
Ahora bien… ¿De qué riesgo estamos exactamente
hablando en este caso?
¿Es acaso el mar el riesgo o somos nosotros
los humanos el auténtico riesgo?
Fijaos, este es el mapa de todas las zonas
ganadas al mar desde el siglo XIV en los Países
Bajos.
Tal y cómo podéis ver, los neerlandeses
han ido comiéndole espacio al mar durante
siglos, construyendo ciudades y cultivos en
zonas con alto riesgo de inundación, zonas
que antes eran agua y que algún día podrían
volver a serlo.
(Al fin y al cabo esto ha sido lo que ha ocurrido
durante millones y millones de años.
El mar ha avanzado y retrocedido hasta dibujar
el gran mapa que conocemos hoy, que se terminó
de configurar hace aproximadamente 6.000 años.
[Vamos, en tiempo geológico prácticamente
antes de ayer].
El problema viene cuando el ritmo de calentamiento
natural se acelera por la acción humana.
Que es precisamente lo que parece que está
ocurriendo.)
Con lo cual amigos, para entender la situación
a nivel mundial y en concreto la de los Países
Bajos podemos decir que nos enfrentamos a
dos grandes retos, y lo cierto es que los
dos son fundamentalmente humanos.
(El primero de ellos es ralentizar el calentamiento
global hacia niveles lo más próximos posibles
al calentamiento natural.
Y segundo, evitar ocupar espacios de alto
riesgo como pólders, que son terrenos ganados
al mar, o llanuras de inundación próximas
a ríos, que son las zonas inundables en caso
de crecidas naturales.)
Os hago una pregunta, si construyo mi casa
en la zona inundable próxima a un río y,
un día, viene una crecida y se me inunda,
¿la culpa es mía o es del río y la crecida?
Tal vez, bajo el punto de vista general, muchos
culparíamos al río, pero, amigos, en los
Países Bajos tienen una cultura de convivencia
con el agua muy arraigada.
Por así decirlo tienen muy interiorizado
que ellos son los invitados.
Es decir, que ocupan un lugar que antes ocupaba
el mar y que tienen que seguir coexistiendo.
Y aquí está lo que les hace diferentes,
especiales. Pero… ¿Queréis saber de qué
diantres estamos hablando exactamente?
Pues..
Fijaos.
(LA BATALLA CONTRA EL MAR, ¿CAMBIO DE ESTRATEGIA?)
Amigos, si algo han aprendido los habitantes
de estas tierras con el paso de los años
es que luchar contra el mar es una batalla
perdida.
Un fracaso seguro.
Veréis, me explico.
La estrategia de protección mediante diques,
barreras dunares, represas y embalses con
el fin de controlar las subidas del nivel
del mar ha sido utilizada durante siglos,
y muy especialmente durante el siglo XX.
(El mayor exponente de esta estrategia pública
de protección frente al mar fue el proyecto
Delta Works o Plan Delta, desarrollado tras
la gran inundación de 1953 que acabó con
la vida de casi 2.000 personas en una sola
noche.
El proyecto se completó en el año 1997,
con la construcción de Maeslantkering, una
gigantesca barrera cerca de Rotterdam con
dos compuertas tan grandes como dos torres
Eiffel tumbadas.
Tardan 2 horas en cerrarse.
Durante las últimas dos décadas, las compuertas
de la barrera Maeslantkering no han sido aún
utilizadas para contener ninguna inundación
masiva, pero amigos, los Países Bajos sacaron
adelante el Plan Delta con el objetivo de
que fuera una protección efectiva durante
por lo menos 200 años.)
Un momento porque hay algo
que estamos pasando por alto.
El Plan Delta es un proyecto del siglo pasado
y lo cierto es que a lo largo de las últimas
décadas el conocimiento sobre las subidas
del nivel del mar y sus efectos ha crecido
un montón.
Precisamente, por eso, ahora, en los Países
Bajos han cambiado de perspectiva.
Veréis, tras Delta Works, los holandeses
han pasado del ímpetu por más y más diques,
cada vez más altos, a las inundaciones controladas.
Sí sí, habéis escuchado bien.
Inundaciones controladas.
De hecho hace muy poquito, en marzo de 2019,
han finalizado las últimas obras del proyecto
Room for the River, un proyecto enorme con
un presupuesto de unos 3.000 millones de dólares,
Un proyecto que ha buscado ampliar las llanuras
de inundación de los ríos donde hay más
riesgo de desbordamiento.
[Vamos, algo así como conducir el agua de
las crecidas hacia zonas controladas.
Suena sensato, ¿no creéis?]
(Uno de los mejores ejemplos que podemos encontrar
de este plan es Eendragtspolder, un pólder
fundamentalmente agrícola en el que se ha
creado una gran zona acuática de recreo.
Sin embargo, como os podéis imaginar, el
ocio no es el principal objetivo de esta inmensa
lámina de agua y canales, sino absorber y
contener el agua durante crecidas y grandes
tormentas.
Se encuentra próximo a Rotterdam y también
al punto más bajo de los Países Bajos, en
una de las zonas más propensas a inundarse
de todo el país.
Esta especie de embalse está pensado para
evitar la propagación del agua durante los
desbordamientos del río Rin, que se prevé
que ocurran una vez cada diez años.)
Pero amigos, no penséis que las cosas terminan
aquí, porque a parte de los nuevos pólders
capaces de absorber crecidas, la política
del gobierno neerlandés y las ciudades va
mucho más allá.
Los ingenieros neerlandeses llevan décadas
preparando al país con vistas al peor escenario
que se vaticina para dentro de mucho tiempo.
100, 200 o incluso 1.000 años.
[Eso sí que es previsión.]
En Rotterdam, una de las ciudades con mayor
riesgo de inundaciones de todo el país, están
creando gran cantidad de espacios públicos
con la función de evacuar el agua y prevenir
así un montón de daños.
(Por ejemplo con la creación de plazas acuáticas
como la de Benthemplein, un plaza que en caso
de crecidas o tormentas convierte las zonas
más bajas del recinto, donde normalmente
hay instalaciones de ocio y deporte, en piscinas
gigantescas donde pueden acumularse hasta
1,7 millones de litros de agua.
Todo ese agua que hubiera generado enormes
daños y pérdidas en las zonas de alrededor,
se va drenando poco a poco para evitar desbordamientos.)
Y esperad porque aún hay más.
Los garajes, sí sí, incluso los garajes
están siendo diseñados como depósitos de
agua en caso de emergencia.
La idea fundamental en Rotterdam y otras ciudades
vulnerables es la de crear la mayor cantidad
posible de depósitos controlados de agua
para poner a salvo las viviendas y las principales
infraestructuras.
[O sea, inundarse pero controladamente]
Y todo esto, amigos, reducirá un montón
los costes económicos tras un desastre natural.
Lo mejor de todo es que esta visión la comparten
tanto la ciudadanía como los políticos.
("No podemos seguir construyendo diques más
altos, porque terminaremos viviendo detrás
de paredes de 10 metros.
Necesitamos dar a los ríos más lugares para
fluir.
La protección [...] en nuestro caso incluye
no solo las grandes puertas y presas en el
mar, sino toda una filosofía de planificación
territorial, gestión de crisis, educación
infantil, aplicaciones en línea y espacios
públicos."
Harold van Waveren, asesor del Gobierno neerlandés)
Y amigos, un momento porque no, todavía hemos
terminado.
En lo que puede resultar algo más controvertido,
el gobierno está expropiando terrenos agrícolas
a granjeros para crear zonas inundables controladas.
Sin preguntar, ni buscar voluntarios.
Te tienes que ir sí o sí.
[La seguridad por delante de todo, eso al
menos es lo que dicen.]
Sin embargo muchos de estos granjeros están
viendo una oportunidad para cambiar, para
crear algo nuevo y adaptarse ellos también
a un futuro con más agua en los Países Bajos.
Vale, es verdad, con el dinero de la compensación,
algunos ganaderos han optado por retirarse,
pero hay otros ejemplos de reinvención mucho
más curiosos.
Como por ejemplo inventar granjas flotantes.
Sí sí, lo habéis oído bien.
Granjas flotantes.
Atentos.
(Con el apoyo financiero de la ciudad de Rotterdam,
la empresa Beladon ha creado la primera granja
lechera flotante.
De momento es solo un prototipo de 2 millones
de euros para 40 vacas que podría producir
medio millón de litros de leche al año.
Si se abaratasen los costes, inventos como
este permitirían a Países Bajos paliar una
parte de los problemas que puede suponer para
su economía la eliminación de terreno agrario
en beneficio del agua, ya que son el segundo
exportador mundial de productos agrícolas,
tan solo por detrás de Estados Unidos, con
más de 90.000 millones de euros en exportaciones
en 2018.)
Amigos, como os hemos contado en este vídeo,
los neerlandeses no se van a rendir fácilmente.
Han nacido conviviendo con el agua y parece
que seguirá siendo así durante generaciones.
Por ello, llevan décadas adaptándose para
el peor de los escenarios previstos: una subida
del nivel del mar de hasta 77 centímetros
o incluso algo más para 2100.
[Tampoco deberíamos sorprendernos de la enorme
capacidad de adaptación que ha demostrado
el ser humano ante todo tipo de escenarios.]
El caso, amigos, es que visto lo visto no
parece que los Países Bajos vayan a desaparecer
bajo el agua.
No al menos en las próximas décadas, ¿no
os parece?
Los escenarios apocalípticos sólo se producirán
si los neerlandeses se quedan quietos durante
décadas o siglos sin tomar ninguna medida.
Y hoy aquí, en VisualPolitik, os hemos contado
que eso no es así.
Evidentemente esto no quiere decir, en absoluto,
que el calentamiento global no suponga un
reto, un reto que tenemos que abordar y lograr
superar.
Como tantos otros.
Sin embargo, lo que os hemos querido mostrar
este vídeo es como algunas sociedades han
empezado a prepararse ya para el mundo del
mañana y cómo tal vez mejor que dejarnos
llevar por el sensacionalismo sea buscar soluciones,
¿No os parece?
Pero ahora turno para ti.
Vale, tendremos Países Bajos para rato, eso
parece claro.
Pero… ¿Crees que llegará un punto en el
que ni los más punteros avances permitan
a los neerlandeses vivir en su país?
Y en el caso de vuestro país, ¿Cómo piensas
que actuaría el gobierno y la sociedad ante
un reto de esta magnitud?
Espero que os haya gustado el vídeo y, si
es así, no olvides darle like y suscribirte
al canal para estar al tanto de lo que está
por venir.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.